hey guys this is vidi with max sec and
today we're gonna answer a question that
some of you may have how well does the
Radeon seven graphics card perform in an
eg PU on Mac OS so why would you want to
do this anyways well the benefit is that
you have a very high powered $700 Radeon
seven graphics card running through an e
GPU with the MacBook Pro and you're
getting excellent graphics performance
much more so than you can get with just
the MacBook Pro itself and we're
actually gonna grab the Radeon Vegas 64
graphics card and see how much better
the Radeon 7 is then the 64 within an eg
PU so to do that we're using the $300
razor core x EG GPU enclosure which has
a 650 watt power supply which is more
than enough to power the Radeon seven
and give an extra hundred watts of
charging to your macbook and we'll have
links in the video description below to
both a Radeon 7 and this razor core X
a GPU enclosure but the main drawback
with a GPU is is that you actually lose
some power compared to having the
graphics card directly inside something
like an iMac or the graphics card inside
the MacBook Pro you're actually losing
some efficiency and we might see less
performance than you get with a card by
itself so installation is incredibly
easy just grab the handle on the back of
the core and pull out the tray then
simply drop the card in screw it into
place so it doesn't move around and plug
in the power cables then slide the tray
back in connect the Thunderbolt 3 to the
macbook and that's it you're done so
I've got it all hooked up I got that
phone about three cable going from the
MacBook to the razor core and I'm gonna
go ahead and flick the switch back here
there you go
and let's go ahead and go into clamshell
mode perfect so you guys can see this
it's a little icon up here says AMD
Radeon 7 so it's hooked up everything's
seemed seemingly working fine as you
guys can see right here Radeon 7 is
hooked up it's not really using it yet
alright so I've got the open see oskol
right here it's about 144,000 which is
very low for the Radeon 7 actually open
it up on my phone here and it's supposed
to get around two hundred and ten
thousand that is a lot more than what
we're seeing here so what we're gonna do
is we're going to run a couple more
tests like you didn't have
actually really quick let's run the Vega
20 that's built into this 2018 MacBook
Pro well as you guys can see we've got
75,000 so just connecting this to the
MacBook Pro you're getting a lot more
performance almost double but that
doesn't mean that it's worth spending a
thousand dollars for the setup so let's
go ahead and test unit in heaven so the
benchmark just finished and we actually
got a really good score surprisingly I'm
gonna pop up a chart and you guys can
see how this compares to a couple other
new Mac systems and yep pretty
impressive so far so we're gonna go
ahead and grab the Vega 64 and we're
gonna pop it in and test it out as well
in goes the Vega 64 very simple alright
everything is connected let's go ahead
and flick the switch
there you go Andy Radeon RX Vega 64 so
let's go ahead and run Geekbench alright
so the testing is done and we actually
got a hundred and thirty four thousand
compares to 144,000 with the Radeon
seven no that's not that big of a
difference at all so at the moment
currently with Mac OS beta software and
probably very very fresh and new drivers
for the Radeon seven there really isn't
much of a difference at all and
comparing it to what you get with the
Vegas 64 in a desktop PC the actual card
itself
you're losing quite a bit of performance
with it being inside a a GPU on Mac OS
so let's go ahead and test Unigine
heaven so it's done we've got sixty
eight point eight fps in a score of 1733
and comparing that to the Radeon seven
we had a score of 1953 so there is a
difference there but is it a three
hundred dollar difference definitely not
now of course there's gonna be more
optimizations newer drivers so the
performance of the radio and seven is
going to increase but it might take a
couple of months to do so before we
finish off this video with some
conclusions we're gonna run some video
editing tests in Final Cut Pro and we're
gonna compare both of these graphics
cards in the e GPU with the MacBook Pro
so the first test we're gonna run is our
stabilization test so we got a clip
right here got a stopwatch
and let's run it see the progress right
up there six point three three seconds
right above six seconds and we actually
tested it with the Radeon seven and we
got five point nine seven so it's just
barely faster really no difference at
all with these two cards which is
surprising so let's get into the next
test
Bruce X so we've got it open right here
we're gonna go ahead and hit share let's
go ahead and run it so the test just
finished and we got 27 seconds compared
to 25 on the Radeon seven so with these
results so far we're seeing that there
really isn't much of a difference
between these two cards so this test is
actually really simple we're just gonna
play this cannon raw 4k 60 clip back and
we're gonna go into our ice stat menus
and we're gonna monitor the frames per
second so we're getting around forty
eight point four forty eight point three
forty seven point three so it's hovering
in that area of around forty eight forty
seven frames per second and if I look
back at my notes we tested the Radeon
seven and we actually got an average of
around 49 fps so the differences we're
seeing here are really consistent we're
getting a little bit higher performance
with the Radeon seven but the biggest
thing to take away from this is that the
e GPU really slows down the performance
of the graphics cards if you put these
graphics cards into a PC you're gonna
get so much more performance so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna make
another video testing the EZ PU and
we're gonna see how much performance you
really lose with basically a bunch of
different graphics cards that we're
gonna test or a few at least so let's
answer our original question is it worth
buying the Radeon 7gp you putting it
into an eg P enclosure and connecting it
to something like the MacBook Pro well
at the moment since Mac OS in beta is
just finally supporting the Radeon seven
it's not worth it because the drivers
are not optimized and you're also losing
performance by putting it into the easy
bu so I would say just hold off on the
Radeon seven and make sure
if you're not already subscribed hit
that button above so you don't miss out
on our ECP you video where we're gonna
be seeing how much performance you lose
with the e GPU so make sure to check out
those videos right there and I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]